okay so welcome everyone to this program
what we're going to be doing in this
program is going over the very basics
and so i want to start by uh briefly
introducing bioinformatics and kind of
i'm asking you to um
you know reply some of the questions so
that we can together think about why
bioinformatics and what what is it
useful for you know why should we
complete this course so first of all
bioinformatics is this a kind of you
know field that
tends to uh you know attract people with
computer science background maybe with
biology background
and the whole purpose of this uh field
is to develop
tools and approaches to analyze data
that comes from the biological domain
and so i think the obvious question that
rises up is
why is bioinformatics actually needed
so
let's go through some of these reasons
together
and if you have any additional reasons
that you think uh
okay sorry about that
so let us uh
change this to here there we go
so why are we
you know interested in bioinformatics
and why is bioinformatics actually
needed so number one lots of data is
being generated right so the
availability of data just the volume of
data all of these
kind of changes in the biological domain
lead to the fact that we have to have
some method of structuring this data
organizing this data making sense but
what is it actually that we are finding
when people generate data for example
biologists
obviously understanding what are the
important things in that data is going
to be very important for you as a
biologist because
in many cases biologists used to just
give this data over to somebody else
someone else needs to look at the data
and try to infer from this data what are
all of the issues that could be coming
with the actual signal that you are
trying to study
when we rely on publications
publications refer to methods of
analysis annotation and interpretation
of biological data because this is a
highly dynamic field methods are often
updated
reference databases are often updated
and also new understanding of what are
some of the basic technical challenges
with different types of data all of
these issues have to lead us to
being up to date and kind of
understanding the language of
bioinformatics
many assumptions are uh
you know when you think of a hypothesis
right when you think of a new project a
new idea that you want to test and you
want to generate some data
before generating data which is
expensive it's very useful to know that
there are many databases where you can
check your assumptions and see whether
somebody else already tried that kind of
an experiment and not only look at the
findings that they report in a
publication but also look at their raw
data so we can find other types of
experimental results
and we can try to infer something from
those
collaborations right in many cases
working together with others requires
you to have a good method of
communication and when somebody produces
some kind of p-value or some kind of
you know number
you want to know what that number means
but also where did it come from and
because people come from many different
backgrounds and approach a data set from
different perspectives if you are the
one that understands the biology of that
data set your you should be equipped to
be
looking and interrogating into that that
data set with an understanding
and number six we see that data contains
noise and artifacts this is an important
point because in so many cases the
assumptions about data and what the data
represents if we just follow standard
methods can be misleading and can
actually be
even bad because we're not taking into
account all kinds of technical
variations so knowing how to address the
technical issues and know what the
issues might be
are all a part of bioinformatics
many different labs perform experiments
to annotate biological phenomena so
because this is a
team effort you know many different
people are involved in similar domains
knowing what else is being available and
and how to interpret that is important
and then finally there are many
applications of data analysis so once
that data is generated many domains
including basic research and
translational research are basing
whatever they're doing on that type of
data so healthcare pharmaceutical
industry agriculture ecological research
biotechnology industries all of these
rely on this data and so knowing how to
generate knowing how to annotate
integrate and analyze this data is very
critical so
bioinformatics
sorry
bioinformatics is essentially the
intersection of information technologies
from the informatics side or computer
sciences statistics with analytical
methods
and the application that
that application
we can kind of group it to be about
biology but in reality there are many
different aspects of application of
bioinformatics and so as we will see in
some of these introductory courses
the applications of bioinformatics in
part is what makes it exciting and in
part it is also challenging because of
the quantity and the quality of data
that these applications that are very
ambitious require
so when we are going to be talking about
all of these aspects in this particular
course a lot of the examples that we're
going to be using come from the
biomedical domain so even though there
are many applications in agriculture and
in maybe biotechnology and other fields
or ecology we're going to primarily be
looking at different types of
applications in the biomedical domain
and in the biomedical domain
we're assuming that the translation of
research comes from a basic
understanding of some biological
phenomena that could be used in clinical
practice ultimately it might not yet be
used in clinical practice it might not
uh ever be used in clinical practice but
it is going into that direction so
what's important is that not only we
need to understand the actual biology at
the level of individual elements that
have to interact and work together and
understanding those mechanisms we also
need to think about the application
downstream so what we're going to be
doing in this program is taking a look
at how
big data this is called big data
bioinformatics can be applied in some
aspect of let's say precision medicine
so what that means is that we're going
to be looking at some aspects of the
diagnostic of the diagnosis of disease
how to detect and determine what a
disease is and the application of
this kind of information to intervention
and typically we think of that in terms
of therapeutics
so the process
of annotating and interrogating
available data leads us to understand
how this data describes a biological
process that typically leads to disease
or accelerates
disease and as a result we can identify
interventions that are either new by
drug discovery or repurposed or maybe
more precise or maybe more defined and
so those are some of the issues that
we're going to be looking at within the
scope of this introductory program
so the introduction will deal with the
intersection of biology and data
and we will also speak about what are
some of the technologies
that allow us to even think about the
way that biological deep biological
understanding of biological processes
and biological phenomena
how can that be translated into the
clinic one of the ways that we can do
this today is because of this
accelerating pace of technological
innovation
and because of technological innovation
we now can very quickly
identify what is going on at the
biological level and translate that to
some kind of an application so there are
two key technologies that we're going to
be speaking about the computational
technology or
ability to process and analyze large
quantities of data
and sequencing technology as an example
of one technological innovations that
has transformed our understanding of
omnics data
so before we move on
let's briefly define
what omnix data is
omix data represents many different
types or collections of different types
of data so for example we can say
phenomics or genomics epigenomics
transcriptomics metagenomics
when we say those words we're referring
to collections of data and those
collections of data represent some very
specific things so for example when we
say phenomics
we typically can mean some kind of a
visual maybe morphological
characterization of data typically
omix refers to high throughput automated
technologies that allow us to generate
large quantities of data so for example
for phenotyping we can use imaging
and then analysis of that imaging data
can help us understand differences
between cell morphology or maybe tissue
specificity maybe identification of
tumors and things like that
genomics refers to the genome what are
the changes in the dna at the nucleotide
amino acid level or structural
reorganization levels such as chromosome
rearrangements copy number variation etc
epigenetics refers to the study of
epigenetic regulation of gene expression
so we can look at epigenomic data like
chip sequencing
by sulfite sequencing
to study dna methylation and chromatin
immunoprecipitation
and
transcriptomics refers to the gene
expression the collection of expressed
genes and transcripts or isoforms of
those genes
and ultimately we can also expand this
to proteomics metabolomics etc so there
are many different types of omics data
in this program we are going to
primarily speak about uh
genomics and transcriptomics and a
little bit about
metagenomics but we are going to do it
at a very superficial level the reason
for this is because we want to provide a
broad overview of how different types of
omnics data could be generated with the
same technology sequencing
and how studying those sequencing data
sets we can find relevant and applicable
biomedically
important pheno
phenomena that we can study
where can we find such data sets
so ncbi the national center for
biotechnology information
is a major resource of freely available
data sets we know that this data set is
not only
rapidly accumulating more and more data
it is also becoming more and more easily
to use so previously you might have
participated in some kind of a workshop
or heard about a workshop on just how to
use ncbi how to find data on ncbi how to
maybe analyze some of the data using
ncbi tools and we're going to briefly
talk about that in this program as well
but we will also see that actually the
website becomes more and more intuitive
the data set are better annotated there
are more of them it's easier to find
them and so once you get a hang of
what's in there you will be able to
start thinking about what can i do with
this
so it's an important resource again over
the years from about
the 90s 1990s up until today
there are over a hundred thousand and we
need to update this slide but there are
over a hundred thousand publicly
available data sets just on one
repository called geo gene expression
omnibus so gene expression omnibus would
of course
have collections of data
from transcriptomics
we will see
how
this data is easy to download or even
even analyze without downloading to your
computer but definitely you will also
find this an important
collection of different types of other
data including metadata about what the
project was about what kinds of
samples are available etc
so this program introduction to
bioinformatics is going to deal with the
following topics
we will talk about bioinformatics in
general what are the emerging
technologies what are some of the
important concepts and what are the
applications of bioinformatics
we will then take a look at some of
these specific types of technologies
dna variations and mutations what are
they how do we find them what do they
mean how do we interpret them
transcriptomics what are genes what are
transcripts how can we measure
expression of those genes and how can we
annotate them to understand how are they
associated with some kind of phenotype
we will also look at some applications
of methods so we will look at
statistical methods of analysis as well
as machine learning so why machine
learning and how do we use machine
learning specifically for biomedical or
biological data
you will be introduced to some tools to
do all of these
including
i will show you in a few minutes some of
the tools that we have for easy
a kind of user-friendly analysis of big
data but also some elements of coding
because it's important to understand
how a bioinformatician might deal with
data maybe what are some more efficient
ways to to start analyzing your own data
or maybe even just looking at data sets
that you already have how to open them
how to get started in that
and then we will look at some of the
projects how do you actually take what
you have learned and apply it to
different examples of data sets taken
from cancer infectious diseases and
biotechnology domains and that will give
you a glimpse of bioinformatics as a
kind of integral component of many of
these different fields
so
this is an overview of the program
because the program is going to be
primarily online and self-guided we're
going to rely on the omix
logic portal so as for hana already
mentioned the omixlogic portal contains
self-guided asynchronous materials that
you can use but also provides you with a
few other resources that i want to go
over
before we go into that does anyone have
any questions about bioinformatics in
general
or what we are going to learn in this
program
or maybe how long the program is or how
to participate in the q a sessions does
anyone have any questions about that or
maybe about registration how to register
for the program if you haven't completed
your registration
okay so if there are no other questions
i will just repeat again
for everyone
this is the portal
learn omixlogic.com
okay we do have a question
is there an exam at the end of the
course yes so we will i will
address that in a moment
okay so let me show you then how this
course will practically work so again
the objective of the course is to
provide you with the resources and the
materials that you can complete on your
own time
but behind the scenes we're going to be
tracking everybody's activity to make
sure that you have completed the minimal
number of lessons and have you know
completed the exercises or quizzes that
are provided within these courses
and if you have any questions we are
here to help we're here to support your
journey and we're hoping to
you know help you complete this
successfully and be able to apply these
skills in some meaningful way
will this course enable us to not only
analyze our own data but also expand to
analyze the many data sets
great question yes so we are going to be
using primarily other people's data sets
we're not going to be using your data
sets in the context of the training
but after you have completed your
training you will be able to analyze
some of your own data
or
use other people's data like i said for
example from ncbi to really understand
uh what's going on in terms of uh you
know other people's experiments
okay so uh as um
um
for hana already mentioned
when you get to the portal
right here on the very top you will find
your email address so let me ask you
here if you already have registered you
have an account please put number one
in the chat box so that i know how many
of you have already created an account
excellent thank you
all right perfect so if you still do not
have an account it's free you don't need
anything to create an account
and later on once you have created your
account we will guide you on how to
complete the program registration so
once you're here if you click on this
you will see
not only like for hana showed the
profile information but down here you
will find a number well for you probably
you will just have one program
and so one of these programs that you
will be a part of
is called uh you know
is the program that we are in now and
this program is called biomed
introduction to bioinformatics biomed
stands for
uh the department of um
for hana can say exactly what
biotechnology and molecular medicine i
believe
at lsu at the vet school at lsu
yeah yeah you're right
okay great
so uh so this program is going to give
you a an overview of
everything that you need to kind of go
through this
for example you will find here the
courses that you have to go through
and you will also see what your
certificate is going to look like at the
end so once you complete all of the
sessions and earn the points associated
with these sessions you will be granted
this certificate here online but also i
will go through some of the other
certificates that you will find inside
every course
you will also down at the bottom find a
link to a slack channel now a lot of
people get confused with the slack
channel you know do i have to join slack
do i have to register for slack
basically every channel you have to
register and once you're registered then
you will be able to
access the discussion
so here you can ask a question
and for example
um
well let's do it like this
uh environment introduction to
bioinformatics
so on slack if you have any questions if
you have any technical issues
you will be able to find it
on slack and ask someone about those
questions
okay so
this is
the slides channel
and
if you do a question like this
for example
okay
so
perfect if you have any uh
if you have issues accessing the slack
channel
you will be
please email this email
and we can help you
okay and so either this one or for hana
if you can add your email there as well
so if you have any questions we'll guide
you on how to do that now why would you
need access to the slack channel
the slack channel is a good way to get
specific answers to your questions for
example you're trying to access the
course and something is not working
you're trying to submit assignments and
you don't know who to send them to
you're struggling with some piece of
code and that code works on our portal
but doesn't work on your system right
this is a place where you can directly
ask those kinds of questions and if you
have um
you know maybe
others can suggest that they know the
answer or our team will actually take a
look at it within 24 hours
so with this program you will see here
the overview right here on top the
choruses
and then also q a at the bottom and the
certificate so we went over those things
as you will see on your profile this
will turn into activity over time so the
activity over time will result in
completed courses so those courses while
you're in this program for the next
three months you're able to take any of
the courses on this portal
all of the projects all of the courses
even the more advanced ones and you
don't have to worry about paying for
anything because if you're a part of
this program everything's already paid
for so you have access to our support
team you have access to the coursework
if you want to try more advanced courses
while you're in this program you're
welcome to do so another important
resource that you will have
available to you is the big data
analysis platform called the t value for
platform
how many of you have already tried
accessing this platform either by taking
one of the courses or just by seeing
that in the description
did anyone try to log in and see if this
is accessible to
you yes excellent
okay
so if you have registered uh for the
learn portal within 24 hours you should
be granted access to this portal as well
if you don't and how do i know that i
have access right here if i hover over
this icon i will see my email address
here as well
so if you don't have access please reach
out to us again in the same email
support at time bio and for hana if you
can add your email there as well that
would be useful
so once you are in here
this will be useful for several reasons
first of all you will be able to
understand how different types of data
is analyzed
by seeing examples so the examples are
accessible
by clicking on this drop down arrow
okay once you click on the drop down
arrow you will find a demo pipeline
this demo pipeline will show you how
individual scripts or analysis
algorithms are connected into pipelines
or workflows
and as you go through the course you
will learn about each one of the steps
that you're taking in this pipeline to
understand what it means and why to use
this one or an alternative and how
specifically to use it so for example
when we speak about transcriptomic data
you will be learning about the basic
steps of transcriptomic data then you
will be shown some limited number of
options that you can try
after you try those options you will
have some results and you can always go
back by clicking
with your right
mouse button
and change your selection
so this is something that you will
use to understand different types of
omics data and eventually
different types of applications of
analysis
okay so in this uh also
in this
section you will find short descriptions
for different types of sections that we
have here
and right here under tutorials if you
just click on tutorials if you need a
quick reference how to use a specific
method
you can go in here and find a much
shorter version
of uh of a brief uh you know
introduction to a section so if you ever
have any questions you can see here for
example how to upload files
or how to
run a particular type of an analysis so
this is a useful resource here as well
okay
so the resources again include
access to the learn portal
on the learn portal
okay gabella is asking how do we gain
access to this do we have to make an
account here as well no you just log in
yeah if you
were already signed up and you had
access to the learn portal all you need
to do is you need to go to this portal
and sign in using the same credentials
if you don't have access your
credentials are not working please email
us
so you can email again for hana or
support
at times
okay so we will try to address all of
the sign up issues and access issues
before um the end of the week as the
program just started
does anyone else have issues accessing
the portal
so i know that cabela
cabela okay chris thank you so if you
could just say that you can't access so
that we can write your name down and
then we can uh reach out to you when
we've given you access
perfect yeah so everyone if you would
like to
okay perfect thank you to sia i think
that some of you just registered today
so it will take a little bit of time you
know after you have registered again for
those of you that are from lsu
you should have completed your
registration through the ilab portal
for those of you that are from nepi you
basically gain access by filling out a
form
we should have emailed you if you just
signed up today then you should get the
email tomorrow and if you don't have
access and you're not from either nappy
lbrn or lsu then please reach out to us
again support or for hana and we will
help you with that as well
perfect thank you kenpel and everyone
else
okay so again how
can you
organize your time to best make use of
these resources in the three months that
we will have
the first section
that we have designed is a section
called getting started so what is
getting started include it includes
three courses one of them is
introduction to bioinformatics that
primarily talks about you know very high
level overview of what is bioinformatics
how's it used different examples of how
it's used in many different exciting
fields etc but it's really an
introductory course now in this course
the first lesson is going to be a survey
this survey is to better understand your
background and to better help suggest
the best course of action for you as you
embark on this journey to learn
bioinformatics
the second course is called bytes and
molecules here you will find terminology
about different things that we will deal
with for example what are genes and how
are they different from isoforms what's
the difference between single nucleotide
variant and single nucleotide
polymorphism what is a mutation how does
a sequence a change in sequence affect
the structure of a protein so all of
these basic concepts are going to be
relied upon in the course work that you
will go through so if you don't know a
lot of these terms you should take a
look at that course first
also you will find there are specific
applications of bioinformatics in the
domains of precision medicine space
omics
and other exciting fields and we'll have
a very short introduction to coding
and then for those of you that are
interested in continuing and expand your
technical skills we have an introduction
to bioinformatics in r and introduction
to bioinformatics and python so i want
to spend just a couple of minutes
ex explaining
what is
what are these
courses and how to use them
so again if you go to the courses tab
and you scroll down here
to getting started
this will take you to the collection
that i was just explaining
you'll have here bioinformatics in
python or bioinformatics and r you will
also find a very brief introduction to
coding
right here in bytes and molecules right
here bioinfo and r
okay so what can you learn in a course
like this
first of all r is a very useful way to
get started with coding especially if
you're a biologist and you don't know
any coding it's very simple
it is free and you will be able to do a
lot of things including images and
figures that you will see in many
publications they were produced in r so
this is a good way to get started and
quickly get to where you want to be in
terms of publications if you're a
graduate student or if you're planning
to publish your research
so
if you click in each lesson you'll have
some kind of a description then you
click on next
and you will be given a very brief
piece of code so you can see that the
actual code here is one line and this
one line describes how to read the table
so this is a major problem for everyone
who's getting started with coding how do
i not just write hello world but how do
i actually load my own data so i can
analyze something that i understand
and so here you will find some data
objects how do you actually deal with
data in a coding environment and then
you will be given several examples
so what can you do with this kind of
data here we take an example from a gene
expression table and so we will look at
different examples of how to make some
plots
and that will give you a good sense of
what is expected
then there's going to be a practical
application so not only do you
load the data right theoretically but
you can run it right here
in
your browser so you don't have to do
anything if you're just learning how to
do r you don't have to do anything
install anything nothing like that and
everything that you do is going to be
using some links to data that we
uploaded to github
so by doing this you're already learning
how to load data and how to manage your
data on the cloud let's say
so the first exercise is just to learn
syntax you can edit what's here
and as you read the instructions this is
very important a lot of people try to do
this without reading instructions read
the instructions
what it says is to
use this you have to copy the link so i
right click on this and i copy the link
and then i replace
this part of the code
with this link
if i have done this correctly
the code is going to load the data into
a variable called df
and then i'm going to check the
dimensions of df so i can just click
here on run
okay and you can see
that success running code but the answer
is incorrect okay so something worked
the data is here
but it is incorrect
so if you don't know why it's incorrect
you need to go back here and you need to
understand the syntax right so what is
the syntax the syntax is how to write
commands
that the computer will understand
because every language has an
interpretive and interpret
interpreter
interpreter sorry so here you would want
to understand what are these things and
how to use this to do what the
assignment tells you
so let's take a look at what does the
assignment says
okay the assignment says check
dimensions
so to check the interventions
you have to write dim
you can clear your code console like
this
run it again and now the code is correct
okay so this is a basic way to use this
console inside your browser
if you are going to be learning how to
code and you're trying to understand how
to code
you know to visualize data to analyze
data et cetera this is going to be very
useful so why the big data platform and
coding
the answer to that is simply because we
are going to be looking at large data
sets okay so i will go again in here
and i want to briefly explain the
difference between these tools a lot of
the standard visualization tools are
going to be available here as well you
will find here different utilities so
you can perform normalization or run
blast or make a heat map and things like
that but we uh these are downstream
things right these are kind of at the
final stages of your analysis typically
one of the biggest challenge is that the
data sets are huge you need to analyze
them and you don't have computational
power on your own
computer your laptop
to be able to do that so processing data
or turning raw large data sets into
manageable tables
or data sets that are structured
you can use a platform like this just to
give you a sense of the size of this
data if you go into the first section
and you click on start you will see
right here the input files
and if you look if you look what are
these files
and and what are the output files right
you will be able to see that each step
of the way creates a number of files
that take in whatever you give it then
produce a file that is the result pass
that result to the next step etc and
this pipeline ultimately will generate
gigabytes and gigabytes of data so it is
not very effective to work with data
sets that have more than several samples
per group so maybe between 10 and 20
samples is a typical
sample size today in an experiment maybe
now more and more towards hundreds of
samples per uh condition so those are
just not manageable on your local
infrastructure and so what we will do is
we will process the data using tools
that are already here we will take the
results that are structured and then
deal with those either again in an
interface like this that is user
friendly or learn how to produce plots
on excel or in r or in python
does anyone have any questions about
this or how to use the coding elements
in these
tutorials
okay if you think of any questions don't
hesitate to
to let me know
now if you briefly go back
to your profile
you will see that all of this activity
is going to be added up so for example
you can see that for
each step
you will get a number of points
and this the number of points
accumulates right here on this left side
and your goal within this course is to
get to 10 000 points
these 10 000 points are going to go
towards your certificate so if you want
to obtain a certificate from either lbrm
lsu
or
neppy you will have to get 10 000 points
how do you get 10 000 points you get
points for individual activities
you get points for completing lessons
courses
and attending sessions these sessions
are going to be either live
or recorded
now if they are recorded
if they're recorded uh you should be
able to
um find them right here
okay so
this is it yeah
if they're recorded you will be able to
find them right here for example you can
see that this is today's session um
yeah today's session introduction to big
data in biology
after today's session these are some
associated online resources that you can
start with for example introduction to
bioinformatics course
access to the educational portal access
to the analytical server all of these
things are something that you want to
take a look at
for example you can click right here and
get to the introduction to
bioinformatics course
or
after you have completed this uh click
on complete session okay so once you
complete the session you see that
session completed is green
again you can go to your profile
and you will see that you get 10 points
for completed program sessions now
these are going to be critical towards
completing the program so completing the
program means that you will have
completed all of the sessions that are
found on this program page
okay so again this is the page
you should be able to see on this page
what i see
which is my profile which you can expand
and kind of see what your
current stats are
and then you should be able to see
sessions that you can complete
if you don't see sessions that you can
complete and here you see pricing
information that means that you have not
uh
been assigned to this program as of yet
and if you haven't that means that we
just have to go through the steps of the
registration and there are several
different steps for registration for
people from lsu louisiana biomedical
research network nepi or outside of
these organizations
okay so after you have gone through this
series of courses
what you should be able to understand is
the role of bioinformatics in
application to different challenges in
biomedicine
in basic and translational research as
well as in industry like healthcare
and pharmaceutical and biotechnology
industries you should also be able to
speak bioinformatics so you should be
able to
converse with somebody who's
knowledgeable in bioinformatics uh maybe
discuss with them methods maybe images
or specific figures that you want for
your publication you should be able to
read through the message section of any
paper and more or less understand what
was being done so that terminology and
the logic behind the analyses that you
typically use in these biomedical
research papers should be more or less
clear
you should also be familiar with the
very basics of coding
not only
understanding how to piece together an
analysis process but for specific stages
of that analysis how would you be able
to do that on your own now that could be
done in excel in r in python
or on the platform so you will be
introduced to a variety of tools
after this
we have regular sessions on different
types of data and so for each type of
the data like genomics metagenomics and
others you will have to go a little bit
deeper to understand how to practically
deal with those kinds of data sets and
see some examples
so that's why we have additional two
programs that are going on right now uh
genomics and metagenomics
those programs are available to anyone
who already has a little bit of
background
do we need to start in an application to
access the class in the link above
well so that link
is for those that are not a part of nepe
lsu or lbrn sebastian so
if you are a part of lsu lbrn or nepi
then there are different
ways to get access so if you type in
chat what you know are you if you are a
part or not i can give you better
directions after that
okay if you're a part of lsu then ilab
is the way to go so uh for hana can help
you with ilab how to get registered
there
so
in parallel to this program introduction
to bioinformatics we have these
additional ones genomics and
metagenomics those are specific to
different types of data and then we also
have a program called data science so if
you already know the basics you kind of
speak bioinformatics you know what the
general idea is you would like to get
more into the advanced methods of data
visualization machine learning deep
learning that is the program for you
data science you you will be able to
learn how to code more effectively in r
and python and you will be able to apply
more advanced methods of analysis and
extract meaningful insights from larger
data sets using coding so that is a
program that is also starting this week
all of these programs are starting
simultaneously if you're just beginning
and you don't feel comfortable doing
this just yet
then you should complete this program
first and then you will be eligible to
participate in the other programs as
well
now after these programs which are basic
programs they speak about the basics of
data types or skills
we then have a series of specializations
these specializations are designed to
introduce you to projects sourced from
publications where we take those
examples from publications and we start
speaking about the methods in the
context of a particular question a
question a research question and so that
is the project component of the omics
logic portal that allows you to not only
apply bioinformatics technically but use
it as a way to conduct research
asking questions developing hypotheses
and translating your understanding of
data to a step-by-step process that will
give you the result that you you're
looking so those divide up into oncology
infectious diseases neuroscience and
agriculture specifically if you're
interested in any of those we have
infectious diseases bioinformatics for
infectious diseases starting soon
if you're interested in that you're
welcome to
write me an email for example
or you will probably receive a notice
about that as well but if you have
specific questions about that program
and starting very soon you can reach out
to me directly so as i mentioned
these are all possible to analyze using
uh the t binomial platform so if you
don't want to do coding you really just
want to understand how these different
elements connect together and how to get
the figure that you need or how to
process data and get the table that you
need
this is a platform that will
suit you the best and you can complete
everything that we discussed today on
this platform itself
including downloading codes to perform
specific types of visualization and
statistical analysis and machine
learning so if you just want to get
those codes and you want to understand
the logic behind the analysis just go
through the steps and then you will be
able to download the code
so to summarize bioinformatics or
introduction to bioinformatics is a
program that is designed to provide you
with a high level overview of some of
the basic things that you need to know
to get started with bioinformatics and
give you access to resources that will
support your individual
path from knowing basically nothing
about bioinformatics to being
knowledgeable and more or less
proficient to do some of the basics and
after that you will be able to apply
your understanding to different areas
either you want to become technically
sound and proficient and bioinformatics
you want to understand the concept of
bioinformatics and the language of
bioinformatics to communicate better
with others and read publications or you
just want to know what bioinformatics is
how is data used in a variety of domains
and how should you prepare for that if
you're for example an undergraduate
student and maybe that will have an
impact on your career as a biologist or
a clinician
with that i am going to stop sharing my
screen
and i do want to ask if you have any
final questions before we close this
session
again the sessions are going to be
available both uh live some of the
sessions are going to be live we will
have some q a sessions
and we will have a synchronous sessions
that are going to
follow some of the
some of the things that we discuss
so
two dates that are important to remember
one date is february 11
and another date is february 18.
those are going to be the q a sessions
okay so i'm going to put this in chat
february
february
11th and
february
um 18.
so these are q a sessions
if you're a part of this program we
highly recommend that not only you
participate but also allow us to prepare
the answers to your questions so email
us or post it on slack and we will be
able to answer your questions in that
session so typically people struggle
with some practical hands-on things
you know you definitely want to be able
to
prepare us to address those questions
specifically and so you can email us
ahead of time
so that our team can prepare for those
again those that have registered already
you will have access to everything that
we discussed today starting today and
all the way up until
the end of
march
if you have any questions about access
or registration please email farhana
lsu.edu she's the coordinator for
everyone that is from lsu louisiana
state university and lbrn louisiana
biomedical research network
for anyone that has questions about
access to nepi the national association
of idea principal investigators
the national uh sorry nepy has
provided us with 50 licenses
for faculty
and students
that come from institutions funded by
the idea program so if your institution
has
a cobri or an inbree
and has funding from the idea states you
will have api who is a part of nepy
if you have such a person typically this
will be a fact guilty member
you can find them
on the neppy website the nebu website
is
n-a-i-p-i dot org i will paste that link
here as well
if you don't know if you're a part of
nippy uh go on this website you will see
there a map
and on this map you can click on the map
and you will see the list of all pis
if you have
that pi's email address or something
like that reach out to them
we will need that information from you
for registration
if you are outside of lsu lbrn or nepe
you are welcome to proceed with the
registration that was on the page that i
already shared
so the page the program page
gives you some uh
sorry
gives you ways to access
the program directly
without funding from an institution so
you can either pursue this direct link
or if you are a student
and you would like to get a
scholarship
please reach out to us as well so the
best way
is
to reach out to marketing and pineapp
bio
or support
pine dot bio
okay how do you check if someone from
our university is not is or is not from
nepy so again the best way to do this
is to go to the nepi
website uh hold up let me switch the
screen
okay so if you go to
nepi
dot org
so this is the link
you scroll down and you will see here a
map so if you know which state you're in
you should be able to click on that
state for example i am in louisiana
and here you will see who if you scroll
down
this will have all of your nepi
uh pi so all of these pis are members of
nepe
so if you see them
they will be either a co-op api or nbi
or a ctr
if you see someone from your university
that is here that's enough right you
just need to mention who that is and and
which university that is
and uh
and then
the nampi organization will provide you
with funding for these programs
all right
any other questions
have the links for the genomics meta
genomics orientation been sent out and
when are those
i do believe that they have been sent
out
so again
let me check my calendar just to see
um
i i do see that we have
a session on wednesday
for genomics
and a session on friday
for data science
so um if you're interested in those
um i believe if you have registered
somewhere you should be getting an email
from somalica ray
or for hana if you're from lsu or lbrn
if you didn't get those then you're
welcome to email me as well and i will
be able to send that information to you
but typically
uh these sessions are going to be at
this time uh from three to four pm
uh first we were going to do it at one
but then some issues with scheduling
came up so now it's at 3 pm
3 to 4 pm they will be recorded so if
you can't participate that's fine we
will send you a recording by link if you
are part of the programs
are there any other questions that i can
answer today
yes 3 p.m central time
when should we expect the emails for the
zoom links for the data science course
again that should be i think the session
is on friday so if you
don't receive it by maybe wednesday
please reach out to us
because of so many different ways to
register sometimes we miss out on
people's information and so if you don't
get those
please do reach out to us and we will be
able to share that with you directly
okay well we're a little bit past our
time so i will let everyone go
thank you for joining today if you do
have any other questions you're free to
email me
if you have other people that you think
are a good fit for this training please
share this information with them as well
and i will be looking forward to seeing
you again in our next q a session
thank you